رصدت كاميرا العربيه اتساع المسطحات
الخضراء في محميه الملك عبد العزيز
الملكيه وذلك بعد موجه الامطار الاخيره
التي شاهدتها البلاد اداره المحميه استعدت
قبيله طول الامطار بزراعه بعض الاشجار
والبذور الموائم مع او المتوائمه مع طبيعه
تضاريس المنطقه مثل الافل والسدر البري
[موسيقى]
من محميه الملك عبد العزيز في الرياض
مراسل العربيه هاني اصفيا انا حياك الله
خذنا معك في جوله كده خلينا نستمتع معك
بالاجواء وبالمناظر في المحميه
نعم اهلا بك خالد واهلا بمشاهدين قناه
العربيه نعم هناك طبعا اتساع واضح في
المسطحات الخضراء هنا في محميه الملك عبد
العزيز الملكيه والتي تبلغ مساحتها اكثر
من 28 الف متر مربع والواقع شمال المدينه
الرياض طبعا هذه الصور الخاصه التي
تلتقطها كاميرا عربيه بشكل مباشر سواء
الصور الجويه او كذلك الصور الارضيه
لاتساع المسطحات الخضراء وتساحه البقعه
الخضراء بعد العمليات
الزراعه التي قامت بعملها الفتره الماضيه
محميه الملك عبد العزيز ضمن مبادره
السعوديه الخضراء وذلك بزراعه ما همم ما
يقارب همم المليون همم شجره طبعا في
الفتره الماضيه وكذلك سواء من انواع من
اشجار او كذلك من البذور طبعا حصيله محميه
الملك عبد العزيز او حصتها تحدي في
مساهمتها ضمن السعوديه الخضراء هي اكثر من
ثلاثه ملايين شجره وبذره سوف تحققها اا
خلال 20/25 ولكن من خلال ايضا همم بعد
الامطار الغزيره التي شهدتها مناطق عده في
السعوديه منها العاصمه الرياض هذه
المسطحات هي لنباتات بريه وكذلك بعض
الطيور التي كانت موجوده هنا وبعضها
المهاجره نلاحظها وان نرصدها عبر شاشه
العربيه في هذه النشره طبعا ايضا لن ننسى
ان الفتره الماضيه وايضا خلال الفتره
المقبله هي ما زالت تسعى ايضا محميه الملك
عبد العزيز الملكيه في تحقيقها للحفاظ على
الحيوانات البريه خاصه المهدده بالانقراض
طبعا لن انسى ايضا ان الفتره الماضيه
يتمكنت من اعاده توطين اكثر من 217 كائنا
فطريا همم انواعها
وكذلك الظبي والريم لذلك همم
عده طيور منها طائر القطا وطائر الحباره
وهي ما زال تسعه ايضا في رفع هذه او رفع
هذا العدد من عمليات التوطين للحيوانات
الفطريه اما بالنسبه لعمليه الاشجار
وتشجير اضافه الى الصور الجويه التي
نرصدها الان ونلاحظ ايضا ليس فقط على مسطح
الاخضر همم المسطح الاخضر ولكن ايضا هناك
بقعه من البحيرات التي تكونت بعد الامطار
الغزيره والتي تشهدها تحديدا هذه المنطقه
التي نقف فيها ونردها وهي في روضه نوره
همم
المناطق ال- ال- ال-
التابعه لمحميه الملك عبد العزيز قامت
بزراعه الاثل وكذلك السجن
في الصور
طبعا نعم الامر هنا مسموح بعمليه التنزه
وايضا عمليه الكشته وهو المصطلح الدارج في
السعوديه وهي الطلعه البريه زي ما نقول و
اذا بنحولها اللهجه البيضاء هي الكشته
مجموعه من الشباب او مجموعه من الاصدقاء
وايضا من السياح اللي هم فتره الماضيه
كانوا يزورون لهذه الروضه وايضا الروضات
الاخرى التابعه للمحميه هي تبعد عن الرياض
لشمال الرياض تحديدا بقرابه الساعتين ونصف
الساعه